اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه مفصله من العربيه نبدا باهم
عناوينها
بريطانيا تؤكد ان روسيا تستعد لحمله تجنيد
جديده تستهدف 400 الف جندي مع طرح
امتيازات للتطوع
مقتل اربعه من افراد الشرطه الباكستانيه
واصابه سته في هجومين لطالبان على الحدود
مع افغانستان
رئيس وزراء الصين يحذر من الانحيازات
الدوليه ضد بلاده ويؤكد ان بكين تعارض خوض
حرب بارده جديده
قاده قطاع التكنولوجيا يعتبرون انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي قنابل موقوته ويحذرون من
مخاطر تشاد جي بي تي
حياكم الله على وقع تصاعد الحرب في
اوكرانيا وما تكبده من خسائر في صفوف
الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني قالت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان هناك تهيئه
اعلاميه في روسيا لاطلاق حمله تجنيد جديده
الحمله مشاهدينا تهدف الى تسجيل 400 الف
جندي جديد اضافت في بيانها اليومي ان
روسيا تتجه لطرح امتيازات للتطوع في الجيش
بدلا من التعبئه الاجباريه لكن نجاحها في
ذلك غير مرجح وقالت الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ايضا ان اعاده بناء القوه
القتاليه لروسيا في اوكرانيا سوف تتطلب
اكثر من مجرد افراد مشيره الى ان روسيا
بحاجه الى ذخيره وامدادات عسكريه اكثر
بكثير مما هو متاح لها حاليا
وبموازاه ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه
عن استعداد جيشها للخدمه مع القوات
الروسيه وذلك من اجل تعزيز الاتصال
والتنسيق الاستراتيجي بين البلدين ومن
جوانبها اوضحت وزاره المبادرات الامنيه ان
بكين وموسكو ستعملان معا لتنفيذ البرامج
والمشاريع على مستوى عالمي
من موسكو تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه كاتيا
مرحبا بك معنا في هذه النشره هناك تهيئه
اعلاميه اذا لهذا
لهذا الملف وحمله التجنيد ايضا جديده
روسيه ماذا لديك من معلومات وتفاصيل كافيه
كانت قد نفت وجود عمليه تعبئه جزئيه سواء
على لسان اللسان الذي تحدث مرارا
ان هناك ان يكون هناك خطه لدى السلطات بان
يكون هناك عمليه تعبئه او موجه تعبئه
جديده في البلاد يوم امس كان هناك حديث
لعمده العاصمه الروسيه موسكو نفى فيها
جميع هذه التقارير وكان قد تحدث ان مكاتب
التسجيل والتجميد العسكريه كانت بدات الان
بالعمل لوجود طبعا
في الواحد من ابريل سيكون هناك ستبدا
عمليه سحب القوات الروسيه الى الخدمه
العسكريه الالزاميه التي تبدا في واحد
ابريل وتستمر لمده ثلاثه وهذا يوقع عليهم
تم التوقيع عليه بمرسوم من قبل الرئيس
الروسي في العام السابق اذا السلطات
الروسيه في نهائيا او كل هذه التقارير
الغربيه التي ليست هي بالمره الاولى التي
تطرح كنا قد شهدنا في بدايه العام ايضا
وجود تقارير غربيه تتحدث عن وجود عمليه
تعبئه جزئيه او موجه جديده للتعبئه
الجزئيه في روسيا وهذا ما تنتهي السلطات
الان حقيقه كما تحدثت عمليه الخدمه
العسكريه ستبدا في واحد ابريل وتستمر
لثلاثه اشهر سيتم فيها قوات روسيه من
ابتداء من عمر الثامن عشر الذين سيخدمون
في لمده عام وكما تحدثت ايضا السلطات انها
لن لا تخطط ارسال هؤلاء ايضا الى ارض
المعركه في العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
نستعرض ايضا هذا الخبر من روسيا حيث اننا
جهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي اعتقال مراسل
صحيفه وولوس اجورنا الامريكيه ايفان
جيرسكوفيتش وبحسب بيان للامن الروسي فان
جيريشكو فيتش يشتبه في قيامه بعمليات تجسس
من بينها جمع معلومات عن المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الروسي لصالح الولايات المتحده
وتم احتجازه وكان اخر مقال نشره يوم امس
في صحيفه وول ستريت بشان تحول الاقتصاد
الروسي الى الانهيار وتقلص الميزانيه
وانخفاض الاستثمارات
كاتيا بشان اعتقال هذا المراسل الصحفي في
الهولوستريت جورنال ماذا لديك من معلومات
حتى الان
بالفعل نايف كانت منذ قليل قد تحدثت وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه عن ان الجيش الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي قام باعتقال الصحفي
التابع الذي يعمل لصالح فول ستريجونال تم
اعتقاله في مدينه برك وبدات وتم فتح قضيه
تحقيق ايضا حول
وجهت اتهامات اليه حول تجسس لصالح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان يقوم كما
قال الامن الفيدرالي بانه كان يجمع
معلومات عن احد المؤسسات المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الروسي وهي طبعا تشكل سرا من
اسرار الدوله كما تحدثت لك هذا منذ الصباح
طبعا حتى الان لا يوجد اي تفاصيل جديده هو
من مواليد عام
1991 هو يعمل في مدينه موسكو او في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو لصالح هذه الصحيفه
ومعتمد طبعا لدى وزاله الخارجيه الروسيه
واجتبها في انه يقوم بجمع هذه المعلومات
التي تشكل تشكل سرا من اسرار الدوله كما
ذكرت لك نايف
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من موسكو مراسله العربيه
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
ناشد مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
على مبادئ تفضي لضمان سلامه محطه
النوويه في اوكرانيا غروسي اوضحها في
تصريحات ادلى بها بعد زيارته الثانيه
لمحطه زابروجيا انه منذ بدء الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه يسعى الاقتراح حل وسط
بين الطرفين لتجنب كارثه نوويه وحضر غروسي
من ان الوضع العام في المحطه لا يتحسن
وذلك تزامنا مع تصاعد النشاط العسكري في
محيطهم انضموا الينا من موسكو عبر سكايب
الكاتب السياسي بسام البني سيد بسام مرحبا
بك معي في هذه النشره ما الذي يخشاه رافيل
جروسي في زبولوجيا الان وفي هذا التوقيت
برايك اسعد الله اوقاتك بكل الكريم صباح
الخير يعني محطه زبالوجيا هي محطه نوويه
وقد اتخذت روسيا كل الاحتياطات اللازمه من
اجل حمايتها من اي استفزاز اوكراني قادم
ولكن مدير المحطه مدير الطاقه النوويه
يخشى من على ما اعتقد دون تصريح منه بانه
كانت تحضر لشن هجوم معاكس نحو مما سيؤدي
الى اهتزاز المنطقه وكما نعلم هناك نفايات
نوويه موجوده خارج اسوار المحطه قامت
روسيا بانشاء يعني مباني خرسانيه من اجل
حمايتها من قذائف قد يعني صغيره ولكن هذا
لا يكفي لانه اذا ما تم تسريب اي
اي مستودع عليه النفايات النوويه الموجوده
قد يكون هناك كارثه نوويه بالفعل ولكن
اوكرانيا لا تريد ان تعامل وروسيا صرحت
منذ فتره طويله انها مستعده للتعامل مع
الطاقه النوويه مع وكاله الطاقه النوويه
من اجل حمايه
وحمايه المحطه من اي احتمال
خطا ما ولكن اوكرانيا تتعنت وتقصف المنطقه
باستمرار الغريب بالامر ان مدير الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه النوويه لا يصرح بتصريحاته
كلها ولا يشير الى انه كان هي من تقصف
محيط المحطه وقد خرج يعني مراسل العربيه
يوما ما من داخل محطه اثناء القصف وقد
يعني اجرى تقريره الواضح والصريح او هذه
النقطه يعني هذه التصريحات هل تعني ان
هناك
مؤشرات حقيقيه واقعيه اليوم رصدتها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه مؤشرات حقيقيه لكارثه نوويه هذه
المحطه المحطه النوويه الاكبر في اوروبا
كما تعلم سيد بسام كل شيء ممكن ولكن انا
اريد ان اشير الى انه البارحه او اليوم تم
قصف منطقه
الكهرباء هناك هذا يعني انه اذا تم انقطاع
الكهرباء عن محطه
للذهاب الى الاحتياط الاحتياطي الديزل
يعني وهذا يعني اننا امام ايقاف للمفاعلات
مؤقت من اجل اصلاح الكهرباء يعني هناك خلل
ما قد يحدث ولذلك ارتفاع الحراره ضمن
المفاعلات ممكن ان يؤدي الى اي شيء ممكن
روسيا تناشر المجتمع الدولي وتناشر مؤسسه
دوليه للطاقه الدوليه للطاقه النوويه بان
يعني تلزم اوكرانيا بعدم استهداف هذه
المنطقه ولكن اوكرانيا مصره على ما يبدو
في الهجوم المعاكس الذي تحضر له اثناء
الربيع بابريل او معي للهجوم من محور
زباروجي بالذات من اجل قطع الطريق على شبه
جزيره القرم والى اخره من التفاصيل التي
يذكره
ليله النهار هذا الموضوع واضح للعيان اما
روسيا فروسيا عملت كل ما من اجل حمايه هذه
المنطقه والمدفعات زاويه لكل الطائرات
المسيره التي توجه نحو المحطه وهنا نحن لا
نتحدث عن يعني عن حل من جانب واحد نتحدث
عن امكانيه وجود حلول يعني بين الطرفين
الروسي والاوكراني كما دعى اليها رافايل
جروسي لتجنب هذه الكارثه النوويه التي قد
تطال قاره اوروبا باكملها هل يمكن التوصل
الى اتفاق في هذا الامر بين الطرفين ام ان
هذا صعب مع تصاعد وحده العمليات العسكريه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه الهجوم المتوقع ايضا
كما ذكرت انت كذلك والهجوم المضاد في
الربيع القادم لا اعتقد ان هناك حل سيحصل
لان هناك خلاف جوهري في رؤيه الطاقه
الدوليه اوكرانيا تريد ان تضع هذه المحطه
دوليه في المحطه وكاله الطاقه الدوليه
تريد ان تكون هي المسؤوله ويعني تكون هناك
قوه دوليه تحمي هذه المنطقه هذا يعني ان
الاختراق سيتم للاراضي التي اعلنت روسيا
انها اراد روسيا وبالتالي روسيا لا يمكن
لها ان توافق روسيا تقول لهم نحن هذه
الارض الروسيه ولدينا محطات نوويه كثيره
ونحن دائما لم يحدث لدينا اي مشكله مشاكل
ولكن اطلبوا من كيف عدم القيام باستفزازات
عسكريه في اتجاه هذه المنطقه ستنتهي
المشكله بينما مديره مدير المؤسسه الدوليه
للطاقه النوويه يقول للروس خفيه تعالوا
على هذه المنطقه منطقه دوليه والى اخره
يعني يريدون الغرب يريد عن طريق هذه
المساله الحق باطل يريد ان يخترق
السياده الروسيه حسب الدستور الروسي بعد
ضم هذه المناطق الى روسيا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من موسكو عبر سكايب كاتبه السياسيه
بسام شكرا جزيلا لك
اعلنا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن
زياره محتمله لنظيره الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين الى تركيا الشهر المقبل لتدشيني اول
مفاعل للطاقه النوويه في البلاد والذي
شيدته شركه روسيا توم الروسيه الحكوميه
للطاقه النوويه
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعد الفاصل ايضا
صندوق النقد الدولي يرى عاما صعبا اخر على
الاقتصاد العالمي في 2023
حياكم الله من جديد قالت الشرطه
الباكستانيه وحركه طالبان باكستان ان
مسلحي الجماعه قتلوا اربعه افراد من
الشرطه الباكستانيه واصاب اخرين في هجوم
في هجومين لطالبان على الحدود مع
افغانستان واستهدف الهجوم الذي اوقع اربعه
ضباط سياره للشرطه كانت تحمل تعزيزات
ارسلت للرد على الهجوم على مركز للشرطه في
بلده لاكي لكن مرواه في اقليم خيبر
بختنقوا على الحدود مع افغانستان كما اصيب
سته ضباط في الهجوم على مركز الشرطه
اصيب عسكريان سوريان بجروح جراء قصف جوي
اسرائيلي طلع مواقع في محيط دمشق وكانت
وسائل اعلام سوريا تحدثت عن سماع دوي
انفجارات اثر الهجوم الذي يندرج ضمن سلسله
غارات تشنها اسرائيل في سوريا مستهدفه
قوات حكوميه وميليشيات ايضا مدعومه من
ايران ومقاتل حزب الله اللبناني
في اسرائيل تتواصل المحادثات حول مشروع
التعديلات القضائيه المثيره للجدل في مقر
الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق هرتزوك بعد يوم
من الاجتماعات مع احزاب المعارضه
المحادثات
ركزت حتى الان على العناصر التقنيه ياتي
ذلك في وقت
تلقي فيه الازمه الحاده في العلاقات بين
نتنياهو الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن التي
ترتبت عن خطه تعديل نظام القضاء
الاسرائيلي فيما تجري وساطات بين نتنياهو
ووزير دفاعه المقال جالنت لابقاء الاخير
في منصبه هذا وشاهدت الضفه الغربيه
اشتباكات مسلحه بين القوات الاسرائيليه
وشبان فلسطينيين على اعقاب اقتحام عسكريين
اسرائيليين لبلدات ومدن في الضفه الغربيه
وتنفيذ عمليات اعتقال ووقعت اشتباكات في
بلده قباطيه جنوب جنين حيث اصيب فلسطينيين
بجروح فيما اقتحمت اليات عسكريه اسرائيليه
احياء في مدينه رام الله
في السودان اكد الجيش التزامه التام
بالعمليه السياسيه الجاريه مشيرا الى انه
ينتظر عملا اللجان الفنيه التي تعمل على
اكمال التفاصيل المتعلقه بعمليه الدمج
والتحديد في الجيش من جهه يعقد المجلس
المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير في السودان
اليوم اجتماعا لاجازه الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي المنتظر توقيعه في الاول من ابريل
المقبل وحسم موقفه حيال هيكله السلطه
السياديه في الحكومه المدنيه
لقد اكدت القياده العسكريه مجددا في اخر
محطاتها العمليه السياسيه تتعثر
انها ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري التي
عقدت لاربعه ايام متتاليه قدمت فيها اوراق
تناقش التفاصيل الفنيه لهذه العمليه التي
يرى البعض انها معقده
التعقيد الذي تجلت صورته هنا بالقاع التي
احتضنت ختاما غاب عنه ممثل الجيش والشرطه
وجهاز المخابرات العامه وحضر ممثل قوات
الدعم السريع حاجات ان الامور كانت تزيد
بطريقه ممتازه وصبيحه هذا اليوم كان يفترض
نجلس ايضا حتى نناقش
المناجيز التوصيات التي تقدم بها الاخوه
العسكريون وفوجئنا انه المساله تاجلت جهاز
المساء
خرجني بما خرجنا به قبل قليل
ورغم المخاض العسير لهذه العمليه والمخاطر
التي تتهددها يظل الامل قائما لانهاء حاله
الاحباط التي سيطرت على الكثيرين ممن
حضروا هذه الجلسه في السبب يخلي الجيش ما
يكون موجود في الجلسه الختاميه لانه انا
ما بعرف الحصل شنو في اللحظات الاخيره لكن
ده ما بيخليني انه انا اكون عندي يعني
معكم متفائله بانه حيحصل لقدام خير وانه
الاتفاق الاطاري حيمشي لمراميه
يصل للهدف بتاعه النهائي
القوه الموقعه على الاتفاق الايطالي ترى
ان اللجان الفنيه ستواصل عملها لاستكمال
وصياغه التوصيات النهائيه التي تشكل عقبه
تسعى الاطراف لتجاوزها هذا وستواصل اللجان
المتخصصه منا العسكريين والمدنيين
النقاشات حول الصياغات الفنيه والعامه
النهائيه للتوصيات التفصيليه لورشه العمل
بغيه نشرها للراي العام وادراجها في مسوده
الاتفاق السياسي الجلسه التي انعقدت بغياب
الاطراف الاساسيه وهما الجيش والدعم
السريع اكدت ان الخلافه بينهما اكبر من
نقاط الاتفاق ورشه الاصلاح الامني اختتمت
اعمالها بلا توصيات الامر الذي يعقد
بالوصول لاتفاق النهائي سالم الهاشمي
العربي الخرطوم
من الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحه والمحلل
السياسي خالد الفكي سيد خالد مرحبا بك معي
في هذه النشره هل يمكن القول بان العمليه
السياسيه في السودان تعثرت في ساعاتها
الاخيره
نعم صباح الخير عليك يا استاذ نادر الكرام
اعتقد ان ما تم هو امر طبيعي وتبا في
وجهات النظر ولكن لا يمكن ان نقول ان
العمليه تعثرت بشكل كامل او يمكن نصفها
بالانهيار لانه هناك ما زالت بارقه امل ما
زالت هناك جهود وتحديات تواجه هذا الطريق
الانتقال هو طويل دون شك فبالتالي اتوقع
ان الان من خلال
اللجان الفنيه المتخصصه من الاجهزه
الامنيه والعسكريه يمكن تسهيل الامر ان
الامر هو يتعلق بضروره وضع جداول الزمنيه
للدعم السريع وادماجه داخل
الجيش الواحد ذات العقيده القتاليه
فبالتالي من الطبيعي ان تشهد مثل هذه
التباينات وهذه التاثرات وربما يعني كانت
هناك مؤشرات السابقه تشير الى ويشاه النظر
والتباين في
كما قلنا سابقا او الحزب المعلومات ان
الدعم السريع يرغب في ان تكون مده الدعم
اكثر من عشره سنوات وان العمليه يجب ان
تكون متكامله عباره عن دمج وتحديث وتطوير
لكافه الاجهزه الامنيه والعسكريه بينما
القوات المسلحه ترغب بان يتم الدمج في
غضون ثلاث سنوات وان يذهب الجميع الى
الانتخابات من دون اي جيوش وان يكون هناك
جيش واحد يحمي الجميع وان يكون تحت مظلته
الجميع فبالتالي اعتقد ان الصيغات هي الان
في هذا الامر فيما يتعلق بضروره او وضع
قيود زمنيه وجداول زمنيه التفصيليه يمكن
ان تقود الجميع النحو الجيش المهني بما
ذلك
دمج الدعم السريع او الحركات المسلحه من
خلال ملف الترتيبات الامنيه الذي هو ضمن
اتفاق جبهه لسلامه السودان
شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم انضم الينا
الصحفيين والمحلل السياسي خالد الفكي
كشفت المديره العامه لصندوق النقد الدولي
كريستاليانا جورجي فعن توقعاتها بان
يواجهها الاقتصاد العالمي عاما صعبا اخر
في 2023 وذلك بسبب تداعيات الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه واجراءات التجديد النقديم
المستمر مديره الصندوق اوضحت ايضا
احتماليه تراجع النمو العالمي الى مادونا
ثلاثه بالمئه داعيه الى تعزيز التعاون
المشترك لاحياء التجاره الدوليه وتنويع
كذلك سلاسل الامداد عشرتنا مستمره وفيها
بعد الفاصل ايضا
مصير المهاجرين في بريطانيا من الفنادق
الى مساكن وسفن
[موسيقى]
مهجور بريطانيا تؤكد ان روسيا تساعد لحمله
تجنيد جديده تستهدف 400 الف جندي مع طرح
امتيازات للتطوع
مقتلوا اربعه من افراد الشرطه الباكستانيه
واصابه سته في هجومين لطالبان على الحدود
مع افغانستان
رئيس وزراء الصين يحذر من الانحيازات
الدوليه ضد بلاده ويؤكد ان بكين تعارض خوض
حرب بارده جديده
قادته قطاع التكنولوجيا يعتبرون انظمه
انظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي قنابل موقوته
ويحذرون من مخاطر تشاد جي بي تي
حياكم الله من جديد اكد رئيس الوزراء
الصيني لتشيينغ ان بلاده تعارض الانحياز
وتشكيله تحالفات وخوض حرب بارده جديده بين
الدول
دعا ايضا الى تعزيز رؤيه الامن الشامل
ومواجهه العقوبات الاحاديه بدلا من تشكيل
التحالفات الدوليه والانحيازات وذلك لمنع
الفوضى والصراعات في اسيا هذا ووصلت رئيسه
تايوان الى نيويورك في زياره اثارت حفيظه
بكين التي توعدت برد انتقامي حل التقاط
المسؤوله رئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
مكارتي الولايات المتحده هي محطه توقف
للتاي المتجهه الى امريكا الوسطى في جوله
تلتقي خلالها
وبليز وخلال عودتها الى تايوان ستتوقف في
كاليفورنيا ومن المتوقع ايضا ان تلتقي
مكارتي وسطه تحذيره صينيه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع في اذربيجان السيطره
على مرتفعات وطرق رئيسيه وفرعيه على
الحدود مع ارمينيا افاد بيان للوزاره ان
مناطق واسعه على طول الحدود باتت تحت
سيطره وحدات الجيش الاذربيجاني وذلك على
خلفيه بدء انشاء طريق جديد في اقليم قرباخ
اعلن الجيش الامريكي اصطدام مروحيتين
اثناء مهمه تدريب فوق ولايه كنتاكي اشار
بيانو للجيش الامريكي الى ان حاله طاقم
المروحيتين غير معروفه حتى الان واوضحت
كذلك ان المروحيتين كانتا من طراز h60 من
الفرقه 101 المحموله جوا ومن جهتها ايضا
قالت السلطات في الولايه انه من المتوقع
وجود قتلى
تطور النهائي المشاهدين تشهده انظمه
الذكاء الاصطناعي لكنه يبدو كما نجح مكلل
ايضا بالخوف حتى بالنسبه لقاده قطاع
التكنولوجيا الذين باتوا ينظرون اليها
بتوجس وكان الروبوتات قنابل موقوته اما
الملياردير
الامريكي فكان قد عبر عن رايه قائلا ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي يوترني بشده وفي هذا
الصدد ومع اصدار شركه اوبن اي اي المدعومه
من مايكروسوفت النقاب عن الاصدار الرابع
من تطبيق تشات جي بي تي وجه باحثون رساله
صادره عن معهد فيوتشر اوف لايف وقع عليها
اكثر من الف شخص من ضمنهم ماسك يحضرون
فيها من المخاطر الجسيمه على المجتمع
والانسانيه لانظمه الذكاء الاصطناعي يدعون
فيها الى التوقف لمده سته اشهر كامله عن
تطوير انظمه انظمه اقوى من روبوت الدردشه
تشات جي بي تي مؤكدين ان مطوري الذكاء
الاصطناعي يخوضون سباقات خارج نطاق
السيطره لتطوير ونشر عقول رقميه اكثر قوه
لا يمكن لاحد حتى المطورين انفسهم من
فهمها او التنبؤ بها او حتى التحكم بها
بشكل موثوق الرساله مشاهدينا شددت الرساله
التحذيريه على انه يجب تطوير انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي القويه فقط عندما نكون واثقين
من ان اثارها ستكون ايجابيه وان مخاطرها
ستكون تحت السيطره
جرعه تفاؤل يصبها استطلاع رايا على الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب الساعي لنيل
الانتخابات عام 2024 التي تمثل بنسبه اليه
معركه وجوديه حيث اظهر استطلاع لارائن
ناخبين الجمهوريين ان اكثر من نصفهم حوالي
54% يدعمون ترشح الرئيس السابق ترامب في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العام المقبل وبحسب
استطلاع الاراء الذي اجرته شبكه فوكس نيوز
الامريكيه فان عدد داعمي لترشح ترامب
يتجاوز ضعف عدد المؤيدين لحاكم ولايه
ابلوريدا رون ديسنتيس وذكر الاستطلاع ايضا
الذي اجري في الفتره من ال 24 الى السبع
والعشرين من مارس الذي شمل 107 اشخاص ان
ديسنتيس حصل على دعم 24% من المستجيبين في
حين ارتفع تصنيف ترامب بمقدار 11% منذ
فبراير الماضي في حين انخفض دعم ديسنتيس
بنسبه اربعه في المئه
في بريطانيا تسعى الحكومه لكبح المهاجرين
الذين يصلون سرا الى اراضيها ووردت انباء
ان ايواءهم سيتضمن اماكن غير معتاده بغيه
تخفيض تكاليف الفنادق حيث اعلن وزير
الهجره البريطاني روبرت جيريك انهم يخططون
لنقل الاف اللاجئين الى مباني تكنات قديمه
ومساكن مهجوره في قاعدتين سابقتين لسلاح
الجو الملكي جنوب شرق وشرق انجلترا كما
وتبحث الحكومه في امكانيه ايواء مهاجرين
في سفن مثل العبارات اذ تسعى الى خفض
الفاتوره السنويه للاقامه الفندقيه
والبالغه 2.3 مليار جنيه
استرليني
تسببت فيضانات في مقاطعه تولير بي
كاليفورنيا بدمار كبير للطرقات وغمره
المحاصيل الزراعيه تحت الماء بالكامل بعد
اعصار ضرب الولايه في الاسابيع الاخيره
اجبر الطقس
القاسي كاليفورنيا
الاف السكان على اخلاء منازلهم نتابع
[موسيقى]
يقبل شهر رمضان هذا العام على الجاليه
المسلمه في فرنسا وسط غلاء الاسعار
وارتفاع معدل التضخم هذه الظروف
الاستثنائيه تنعكس بشكل مباشر على مظاهر
الاحتفالات المرتبطه بالشهر الفضيل فقد
تسبب ضعف القدره الشرائيه للمستهلكين
بتراجع الاقبال على الاسواق الشرقيه
[موسيقى]
طاهر ومحمد شريكان في مطعم تونسي يقع في
احد الاحياء الباريسيه مع بدايه شهر رمضان
لاحظ انخفاضا نسبه اقبال الزبائن علما ان
تجارتهما كانت تزدهر في هذه الفتره من
السنه لكن ازمه التضخم حاله دون ذلك حسيت
اقبل كنت
خير ربي
[موسيقى]
مع حلول شهير رمضان حاله من الركود تسود
الاسواق العربيه في فرنسا فمظاهر الاحتفال
بالشهر الفضيل هذا العام اصبحت اقل حضورا
من ذي قبل نتيجه ازمه التضخم التي ضرب
البلاد على القدره الشرائيه للمستهلكين
غلاء الاسعار هذا العام جعل تكلفه المائده
الرمضانيه اكبر بكثير مما كانت عليه لذا
اعتمدت العائلات المسلمه سياسه التوفير
لتجنب الاستهلاك غير الضروري من كثروش
منها اكثر من اللازم على خاطر غاليه احنا
نعيشه هنا في الخارج عنا
برشا حاجات نخلصوا فيها منجموش
نتعدوا اكثر من لازم ناخذه نختاروا
الحاجات الضروريه
نسحقها كل يوم
وناكلوها معناها
على الحاجات
منطيشوش وتشير الارقام الاخيره الى ان
معدل التضخم في فرنسا تجاوز عتبه السته في
المئه فيما قفزت اسعار المواد الغذائيه
بنسبه
14.8
زين عدي العربيه باريس
من شاب معدم الى اكبر تاجر في منطقته هي
قصه مسلسل باب المجال بطوله مصطفى شعبان
وباسم سمره وسوسن بدر بالاضافه الى جمانه
مراد احداث المسلسل تدور في اطار دراميين
شعبي مليئه بالاكشن والاثاره وتناقش ايضا
قضيه اجتماعيه مهمه المزيد عن هذا العمل
في تقرير الدراما لساها الوعل واعداد ايهم
القاسم
[موسيقى]
اول حد قدرته وكان مين من الضحايا
هنوضحيها عندي كتير يا باشا انا بابا
المجال
[موسيقى]
بابا المجال للفنان مصطفى شعبان وقبل
رمضان وهناك حاله فضول وجدل كبيرين والان
وبعد ايام من عرض العمل يبدو ان الجمهور
اهدا ربما اعجابهم القصه التي تدور في
منطقه شعبيه يمر فيها البطل بمواقف وازمات
حيث يعمل في مجال التجاره ويواجه خصم شديد
جدا وهو باسم سمره لا انا بشوف انه مسلسل
شيق لانه قصه شعبيه
بتلمس كل واحد ماشي في الشارع
تلمس كل واحد في سواء في منطقه شعبيه او
مش في منطقه شعبيه في مصر او كمان في
العالم العربي
سنستكمل هذا التقرير في نشاطنا القادمه
الان نختم هذه النشره بابرز عناوينها
بريطانيا تؤكد ان روسيا تستعد لحمله تجنيد
جديده تستهدف 400 الف جندي مع طرح
امتيازات للتطوع
مقتله اربعه من افراد الشرطه الباكستانيه
واصابه سته في هجومين لطالبان على الحدود
مع افغانستان
رئيس وزراء الصين يحذر من الانحيازات
الدوليه ضد بلاده ويؤكد ان تعارض خوض حرب
بارده جديده
قاده قطاع تكنولوجيا يعتبرون انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي قنابل موقوته ويحذرون من مخاطر
تشات جي بي تي
شكرا لكم المتابعه دائما العربيه
والمعلومات الزميل خالد مدخل يلقاكم على
راس الساعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]